let me just remind you this is a a
cartoonist called coco ray corey and ray
she
has told a french newspaper louis
manatee
that she'd gone to collect her daughter
from nursery school i presume
and as she arrived at the front door of
the paper's building there were
two hooded armed men who threatened them
they wanted to go inside she says to go
upstairs i
entered the code so this lady let them
into the building
clearly being threatened they fired on
wolinski
and kabu now walinsky and caboo are two
of the other cartoonists
who we believe are among the dead it
lasted five minutes she says
i sheltered under a desk they spoke
perfect
french they claimed they were from al
qaeda
so now we have a proper eyewitness from
inside who let them in clearly with her
small daughter
it seems what a horrifying experience
for her
but clearly spoke perfect french not
broken french
and claimed they were from al qaeda
hence the question i suspect
for the interior minister there were
they from al-qaeda as he walked away
so we're getting a picture of these
people if they weren't french nationals
they spoke the language they threatened
her they knew who they wanted to shoot
at
they killed these people inside
including the cartoonist
and she says it all lasted about five
minutes